-Performing "Lee & Lovie"
and "Blu Billy"
from his new album,
"Luv 4 Rent,"
give it up for Smino.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
-[ Whistling ]
-[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
-♪ Ohh, I think you're lovely ♪
-♪ Lovely ♪
-♪ Ohh, I know you care ♪
♪ Yes ♪
♪ Oh, like Lee and Lovie ♪
-♪ Like Lee and Lovie, oh ♪
-That's my grandma and my papa,
now, you know what I'm saying?
-♪ Oh oh ♪
-♪ Oh, tryna' get over
what I'm used to ♪
♪ Has anybody ever used you ♪
♪ Beat your heart
black and blue? ♪
♪ You know about it,
you know about it, 'bout it ♪
♪ Fell on my head
a few times ♪
♪ I lost a couple screws,
oh-oh-oh, child ♪
♪ I'm not one to pick
and choose ♪
♪ But you know you got it,
you know you got it, got it ♪
-♪ Oh, I think you're lovely ♪
♪ No-no-no-no no ♪
♪ I know you care ♪
-♪ You know you got it,
you know you got it, got it ♪
♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Ohh, I think you're lovely ♪
♪ No, no, no ♪
-♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ You know you got it,
you know you got it, got it ♪
-♪ It's been a minute since
I told you 'bout the rent due ♪
-♪ You been lettin' me slide ♪
-♪ I wanna stay and be a tenant
if you got room ♪
-♪ For the rest of my life ♪
♪ I put my credit on the counter
and my debit, too ♪
-♪ Put my credit on the line ♪
-♪ Oh, oh, I just got my fingers
crossed, one of 'em go through ♪
♪ Hey ♪
-♪ Oh, no, no ♪
-♪ I got both my fingers crossed
no more of my people lost ♪
♪ But we done seen so much,
we just tryna see the Cross ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, unh ♪
♪ Ah ♪
Hold on.
[ Rapping ] ♪ We are now
boarding the lover-craft ♪
♪ Make you feel warmer
than a baby laugh, oh ♪
♪ Baby, you forgot your ticket,
it get wicked ♪
♪ Just pay me cash ♪
♪ And if you ain't got that,
just pay me mind ♪
♪ I'm the love lord ♪
♪ Just tryna lose less
and love more ♪
♪ I tell you what --
it's on the house this time ♪
-[ Vocalizing ]
-Right.
♪ Li'l Monte on the beat,
you got it on repeat ♪
♪ Word out in the streets,
the zero got the heat ♪
-[ Vocalizing ]
-♪ Unh, I know, I know, I know ♪
♪ I, oh, I know, I know ♪
♪ And I really don't feel
no difference ♪
♪ We all ♪
-♪ Hustlas ♪
-♪ Blu Billy,
we conditioned by conditions ♪
♪ Capitalistic,
read through the lipstick ♪
♪ That they make up,
make us forget it ♪
♪ I beat your face up
if ain't no paystub ♪
-♪ By Friday ♪
-[ Vocalizing ]
-♪ I don't wanna lay up ♪
♪ Assalamu alaikum in L.A. ♪
-♪ I know, I know ♪
-♪ Very, very sweet ♪
-♪ Busy you, busy me ♪
♪ Like how busy can busy be? ♪
♪ Hardly catching Z's ♪
[ Snores ]
♪ No fatigue ♪
♪ Hate it when it rain,
Missy E ♪
♪ Nefertiti chain,
oh, she deep ♪
♪ Eat her with a spoon,
call her Reese ♪
♪ Then we burn them calories ♪
-♪ Ah, ooh ♪
♪ I couldn't give you
a better reason ♪
♪ Mess with you
'cause you mess with me ♪
♪ Met with me,
yeah, you met with Smi' ♪
♪ Told them girls to beat it,
Sheila E ♪
♪ Eat a D, diss the E.N.D. ♪
♪ PND playing on the speaks ♪
♪ Tryna phone full Brittney G ♪
♪ Straight up ♪
♪ Entrepre-bigga,
entrepre-bigga ♪
♪ I did it all on my own ♪
♪ Entrepre-bigga,
entrepre-bigga ♪
♪ I did a lot on my own ♪
♪ Entrepre-bigga,
I'm just a -- oh ♪
♪ I did a lot, ooh ♪
♪ I did it bigger
I did it bigger ♪
♪ I put the clip in,
I pulled the trigga ♪
♪ I made the whole gun,
I Smith & Wess' them ♪
♪ Stay with the bro-bro,
yeah, with the brethren ♪
♪ Stay with the throat-goat,
greatest Excedrin ♪
♪ She ain't no ho,
I'm just a legend ♪
♪ This ain't no promo,
this is Jimmy Fallon ♪
♪ Hey, yeah ♪
-♪ I know, I know ♪
♪ I know, I know ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]